parlons de huawei parce que ils ont sur
l'invitation de l'événement qui aura
lieu dimanche prochain
montrez ce grand v ce grand v c'est leur
smartphone à écran pliable et ce grand
veille sur la photo on dit beaucoup plus
que ce qu'on pourrait penser
[Musique]
good news
regardez pas j'ai reçu des nouveaux
produits et je suis super content de
pouvoir vous en parlait peu nerd is
light on va en parler dans quelques
jours et demi notre set de chiots me on
va également en parler dans quelques
jours donc ça c'est pour les bonnes
nouvelles
alors rassurez vous il n'y a pas de
bonnes nouvelles tout va bien tout se
passe bien je vous prépare un départ
pour londres dans quelques jours qui va
être juste énorme pour aller voir les
nouveaux smartphones va pas compliquer
le micro part en cacahuète pour aller
voir les nouveaux smartphones de samsung
et je fais tout en même temps que j'ai
ça devrait aller
ça va alors ouais ça a marché donc d'ici
quelques jours départ pour londres
on fait un petit crochet ensuite on va
les voir xiaomi non pas pour leurs
courses de presse j'y serai après en
quelques jours mais pourra les découvrir
leurs nouveaux locaux ça ça va être très
sympa
cette semaine on va voir un programme
hyper intéressant fait cette semaine la
semaine pro parce que je commence à
diffuser cette vidéo dimanche
voilà type d'info et ensuite on file
direct sont barcelone pour aller voir la
conve le chili
l'acompte de huawei compte de sony il ya
huit kofler plein de monde à lire des
trucs de fou on va parler 5j enfin
d'ailleurs les trucs incroyables vous
invite dès aujourd'hui à vous abonner
comme ça on va tout de suite ça va être
vraiment très justement parlons de
renvoyer parlons de huawei parce que ils
les ont sur l'invitation de l'événement
qui aura lieu dimanche prochain
montrez ce grand v ce grand v c'est leur
smartphone à écran pliable et ce grand v
sur la photo on dit beaucoup plus que ce
qu'on pourrait penser et c'est vraiment
hyper intéressant je veux si tu contexte
les smartphones écrans pliables n'ont
jamais été aussi proches
on est à quelques jours de l'annoncé de
samsung de huawei de tous les autres qui
vont arriver derrière ça va être juste
énormissime on en parle depuis 2011 on
sait qu'un concept qui va arriver il ya
rouillac a présenté sa copie un peu un
coup d'épée dans l'eau un grand coup de
com pour eux mais en tout cas les vrais
beaux smartphones à écran pliable ont
pointé leur nez d'ici quelques jours et
ça va être juste énorme
maintenant une question primordiale quel
mac va vous proposer la solution la plus
proche des attentes des consommateurs ou
du besoin des consommateurs
alors vous allez me dire
j'ai pas d'attentes j'ai pas de besoin
c'est un nouveau produit on est en train
de le créer un besoin
oui et non oui et non parce que calais
travail d'une marque c'est d'essayer de
voir les tendances et vous présentez
vous proposez les produits les plus
proches de ces tendances là vous me
direz entre 2011 l'idée où ce concept
est né et 2019
il s'est cru aimer couler quelques
années mais en tout cas on voit vraiment
cette grande tendance des écrans plus
grands des device plus petit donc un
moment sans forcément passer par une
solution les plier est une bonne
alternative
alors justement on va s'intéresser à la
copie de huawei au final on sait pas
grand chose
merci monsieur groupe pour cette vidéo
bisous à bientôt on sait pas grand chose
mais on devine pas mal de choses alors
on va déjà se concentrer sur ce qu'on
voit on voit ce grand v avec une lumière
qui parle de chaque côté ce qui nous
montrent effectivement qu'on va le
replier comme ça et qu'on aura un écran
de chaque côté donc on est donc assez
proche de ce que nous a présenté auriol
un smartphone qui se plie avec les
écrans sur l'extérieur vous l'ouvrez
vous avez une grande table est
probablement de 8 pouces est fermé vous
aurez deux écran de 5 pouces alors ce
qu'on imagine très bien c'est bien
évidemment lorsqu'il va être fermé comme
on est petite prise de notes comme ça et
bien vous allez aussi avoir une petite
notification probablement sur la tranche
ici sur lequel vous allez pouvoir voir
des motifs des choses qui vont
apparaître disparaissent quoi les choses
qui vont se créer c'est ça qui est
vraiment très intéressant et un d'écran
qui sera verrouillée en tout cas l'écran
du dos sera verrouillé ou que vous ne
pourrez pas utiliser lorsque vous
utiliserez l'écran du haut et
réciproquement
donc ça c'est assez intéressant c'est un
maître arabe d'aller plus loin pour la
gestion du multimédia pour le multitâche
pour pas mal de chose savaient vraiment
hyper hyper cool ce sera donc un écran
oled
elle sera état puissant il va tourner
sur un kirin 980 mousse et à
l'intelligence artificielle avec le
nouveau modem 5 g que vous voyez a
présenté il ya quelques jours
si on regarde les images on voit
également c'est quelque chose qui est
très fin avec des toutes petites bordure
donc on devrait voir quelque chose au
final qu'un vrai beau format pocket
on va pas avoir cette espèce de deux
grosses charnière comme on achir orioles
qui pas une très très belle finition un
produit bien fini
aux puissants performant grand ça
pourrait franchement à ce qu'on vend
tout cas être une vraie révolution alors
maintenant la question c'est quelle est
la proposition qui va être la plus
intéressante on se replonge en plus on a
donc ce format comme un livre que vous
allez ouvrir
vous avez votre grand écran vous repliez
écran sans l'extérieur ça c'est la
proposition aux orioles et priori la
proposition va nous faire ou à louer
d'ici quelques jours la proposition de
samsung va être franchement différentes
on l'a vu en catimini lors de sa
conférence des développeurs fin 2018 ce
sera donc un smartphone avec un seul et
grand écran vous leur fermerait et vous
aurez un écran en face avant
probablement aussi un écran de 5 pouces
donc on n'est pas du tout sur la même
proposition que sur la proposition de
samsung on aurait donc un écran en plus
sur l'extérieur intéressant et vous avez
une troisième proposition qui est la
proposition de xiaomi qu'ils ont dévoilé
lors d'un teaser qui était publié sur
weibo palin john ça c'est intéressant
parce que là pour coup il va pas se
plier en deux il va se plier en trois
pourquoi pas vous avez un grand volet
principal est de voler à rabat qui vont
venir se poser sur le côté pourquoi pas
ça peut aussi être intéressant donc je
sais pas vous ce que vous en pensez qu
est ce qui vous paraît avoir le plus de
sens un écran qui se rabat sur
l'extérieur un écran qui se rabat sur
l'intérieur avec un écran à l'extérieur
ou alors des volets qui se replie de 1,3
je sais pas c'est vraiment des
propositions de valeur différente et au
final est ce qui fait que le plus
intéressant c'est que il est évident que
dans ces différentes propositions il y
en a une je pense qu'il va marcher qui
va tirer son épingle du jeu et deux
autres qui vont un peu se casser la
gueule donc quel sera le vainqueur qui
va vraiment réussir et ce qui est très
intéressant c'est que chaque marque je
compte par google parce que oriol ça
plus un coup de marketing
je l'exclus de ce point de vue là même
si effectivement ils ont été les
premiers à le faire donc je critique pas
mais je l'exclus fondamentalement plus
leurs produits pour moi ils passaient
abouti huawei samsung xiaoli lequel va
vraiment réussir trois propositions
différentes et ce qui est très drôle
c'est que ils ont réussi à sortir trois
propositions différentes or comment ils
ont réussi à savoir ce qu'allait
proposer d'autres parce que sur ces
trois gros acteur majeur il y en a pas
un seul qui propose la même chose ça
c'est très intéressant
donc si vous avez une petite idée sur la
question il est à remarquer en bas un
commentaire dites moi vraiment ce que
vous en pensez
je pense que là on a vraiment fait un
peu le tour sur les différents concepts
sur ce qui pourrait arriver
on se retrouve dans quelques jours le 20
février prochain directement à londres
on filera ensuite à barcelone on aura la
proposition de samsung au nord la
proposition de huawei au sud et celle du
chien au mieux on verra dites moi ce que
vous en pensez en commentaire qu'est ce
que vous attendez de ses smartphones à
écran pliable on va reparler
prochainement
on va attendre de leader à peu pris en
main puis nous donner mon retour mon
ressenti pire on parlera du concept en
lui même de ce qu'on peut faire avec
vous allez voir c'est hyper cool vous
invite donc à vous abonner pour tout
savoir en direct d'ici là soyez sages
vous embrasse et puis vous marquez tout
ça ils vous disent que vous en pensez à
bientôt tard